James on the love and Davis Samba
throwdown
one of the greatest passers in the
history of the game in the bunt with a
target like that that's a pretty good
combo to dodge its to anybody this time
foul come on that team they got 61
points from the reserves nice pass nice
cut Luka just finds in people left and
right
61 points on a night where Luca and
Chris tab struggled shooting the ball
Bradley in the corner connects sata3 get
him underneath the hoop 7 for 290 can do
a lot soak in that body LeBron James
muscling inside for the leg this is
where he usually gets himself
I'm sorry it was Hardaway much of a
impediment on the way to the rim money
just discarded them I don't think James
was too worried no James on the attack
had the angle and able to muscle in the
finish we see why a good percentage of
the shots come from just prototypical
LeBron James night I mean to be honest
with you Hardaway is in really bad
defensive position if you're not level
up with him and you've got one foot high
he's going to attack you and it becomes
defense hasn't exactly been a strength
for Dallas to begin this season 21st in
rating oh what a feed from LeBron James
somehow threading the needle to Bradley
12 points four rebounds five assists for
LeBron James
Danzig you been
beautiful cross gets separation when
necessary gets the switch to LeBron just
that pullback dribble to get it back to
where he wants it so Jamal Mosley and he
work off and on this one-on-one skill
and it stays with the Lakers shot clock
turned off James fires it down and
caldwell-pope finishes it Akers have you
extended back to the end of the second
on a 12o run a chance to tie or take the
lead here
Bradley ties it don't judge had to be
careful playing with three fouls 610 7
feet as you're trying to make a layup
good luck porzingis plus the foul JaVale
McGee has his head turned a little eye
contact between porzingis and luca and
you could see the frustration and it's a
subtle thanks certainly plenty of Lakers
fans in the building is don't judge
answer
telephone apartment goodness James no
look on the money to Danny Green
just watch the passing I mean Don she
just got his head away from LeBron
defenders head is not facing the
basketball as he hit him
responding just incredible James 23
points 10 assists five rebounds as
Dobson makes it rain
James had it by a wide margin but the
hard dribble act is what makes that
racialist mixing pace and feel and fakes
size strength IQ and that [ __ ] him right
there see you talking it so on the catch
he lifts with a little up fake get some
crossed over
once he earlier tonight before this game
start he thought they've had a chance to
be down the wire and special feels that
way as cleaver buries a three on assist
number 10 from Lucca and he's gone to
his three point game he sold for five so
if it's not flow and get to the post Oh
finish that [ __ ] son when no one else
did sit back here comes James James
running the break the pirouette and the
finish
outstanding no call Don Cheech loves it
a flavor
oops Lee alley
but career-high 13 assists palooka donk
donk just going to hurt you so
Dwight's just trying to corral them
porzingis lost it again and this time
james controls it james all the way
James is put the Lakers in front for an
intensity on that end that I've seen in
a long time
I mean the ball comes loose yes he's in
a great position with end to end this is
still a bad man and his hit big Nullah
Bradley frantically communicating the
defense Dantas lobs it in Powell
finishes
Iike using the Powell screen a
hesitation the drive pick three get it
so they run some initial action with
kristaps porzingis little flare screen
but this was the action they're trying
to get to so the change of pace the
switch that's elapsed from the strong
quarter by Danny Green and boom Dorian
finney-smith I mean how about that
little hesitation to get Anthony Davis
stood up
historian finney-smith and they've come
on down there is Bradley James James
going to the rim kicks to the corner
Green a three to tie he got it
[Applause]
and Danny Green is a guy that has made
big shots in the NBA Finals that scream
from Dwight a beautiful plate is set up
city Smith for the go-ahead 3 as the
Mavericks turn it over there there is
James threading the needle to Davis for
the finish now 6 of 15 James finishes
and the foul
if they went right at it I think they
know Lukas hurting a little bit and so
they they scream with Avery Bradley got
the switch they wanted it oh my goodness
the power that's very fair on your part
Don Cheech
[Applause]
into the arms of Luka James isolating
against Dante's a bomb you bet he's not
an answer tonight gets the switch on to
Luca he's looks so confident comfortable
with that three ball tonight is he not
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content